on this episode we talk about 71 years
old podcasts and what happens when you
get sick you ask questions and I answer
them this is the askgaryvee show
[Music]
what's up everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 74 of
the askgaryvee show
had a great time in Napa Valley this
weekend big shout out to everybody there
really enjoyed that really enjoy the
fact that Stefan is behind the camera
today I don't want to look at d-roc
that's good
very excited about my video going I
don't wanna use the word viral but we
have a video going crazy on Facebook my
Monday video which we also put up on
YouTube Stefan get it up here though I
think the rock might be editing this I
did see something going on whose is d
rock editing a little double combo
editing for episode 74 India show India
I always like we show her let's get in
to the show Brendan asks Gary what's
your take on podcast you're playing in
the space but not all in not worth it
yet
Brendan great question the only reason
I'm not all in on the podcast right now
is because I'm too busy meaning
everybody has to kind of decide
opportunity costs and for me I think I
over index on video I perform better on
video I like video more I like this
whole thing right you weren't ready for
that stuff on that's what happens I'm
working you up so I'm half pregnant
because I'm transcribing this show into
audio form big shout outs everybody's
listening on the podcast cuz I know a
ton of you are on the way to work I
think podcasting is a huge phenomenon
obviously the smartphone has changed
dynamic people can take it with them
when they're running and working out
people are clearly Bluetooth thing it up
in their cars
public transportation podcasting has
clearly exploded over the last 24 months
things like serial became a national
phenomenon out of podcast form it's fun
for me to watch because podcasting was
really vagin oh four and five if you
think about what uh whatever Williams
did he did oh do in between bloggers and
Twitter that was podcasting I'm all
about podcasting in its traditional form
as an audio vehicle to me I think it's a
huge play I highly recommend a lot of
people doing it let's never forget a
hell of a lot more people can do the
audio version versus the video version
here this takes really another not
another a different dimension and skill
set one that I think I own
thus I go this route and then use the
audio to create two pieces of content
video and the audio form and and and
from and by the way podcast listeners
please hit up Twitter and give me your
feedback I think I've been trying very
hard even the opening like instead of
saying you're watching episode 74 ends
and this is a bit like I'm trying to
make it a little more native for both so
I'm trying the best I can to be podcast
oriented in the form of your question it
is a byproduct of it being video first
if I had time to do two separate shows
like so many people have asked me to I
would I don't see the ROI return on just
audio for what I'm doing for a living
right now and so that's this that was I
was held up a pillow that says
vaynermedia for all your podcast people
let's go the next question
hey Gary Spiker Helms here I was
wondering if you created a social media
platform what would be your key feature
and why can't wait to hear your response
see ya see ya
so I've long had an idea and I'm going
to share it with you guys which is the
notion of the a social network that
looked like Instagram but more like path
like you could put any piece of content
can be a picture of video audio file or
more content agnostic so not just
picture a video but also the ability to
do audio on top of that but the whole
website the the whole app the the whole
social network was predicated on the
notion that you can only speak once a
day for in any 24 hours so as soon as
you put out a piece of content you would
no longer be out able to put out another
piece of content until 24 hours later
because my belief is that the supply and
demand of noise is the real issue with
social networks path went down how many
people you follow I think it's the
amount of pieces of content I still
think it's gonna be a big business I
still think that restrictions is where
the action is for short term and I would
not be confused if we all look back at
this video and talk about how I
predicted somebody going and executing
this billion dollar idea I think the
restriction of one piece of content
today is where it's at because it forces
all of us as content providers which all
of us are to put up the best piece of
quality content because it's that
restriction Plus
the oomph behind it imagine I'd say
happy birthday Alex and that was the
only thing I could say that day Wow in a
world where there's so many many other
things I want to put out so my social
network would be predicated on one piece
of content per person a day phone for
life asks Gary I'm 71 years old how can
i filter years of exciting adventures
and experiences into value that someone
would actually be interested in Carolyn
first of all that is my favorite picture
that has been put up on Instagram so far
is a phenomenal picture thank you so
much thanks for listening watching the
show by the way this is a good time to
just say get your questions on the show
using Instagram look at that execution
as inspiration um look I I don't know I
you know are you're 71 years of
experience interesting does anybody give
a crap I mean I'm you know I just went
from such a lovely place to such a
negative place throwing curveballs out
there like we do on Mondays Mondays show
Monday video that's two times you got to
put in there Stefon if they're doing the
editing I don't know which ones you're
having which was the other half so
really when it comes down to his value
it's all value exchange you know I very
much value somebody who's lived 71 years
long for life advice just on living
right but what also matters is how
you're going to communicate it and in
what form are you gonna monetize it do
you want to put out a show where you
answer questions or put out content or
tell stories but then how are you gonna
monetize it advertising I mean there's
just so many open-ended questions that
need to be asked of you based on your
question but here's what I would say
there's a lot of ways to make money you
can have subscription you can have
coaching you can sell content you can
sell advertising you can build up equity
by putting out content and putting on a
conference there's a ton of ways you
know I really do think I'm one of the
golden examples of how to make money
without directly selling it meaning
again there's a lot of my contemporaries
who sell ebooks or white papers or
access to their VIP place I do run such
things I put out the content at scale
hence this show but then a build brand
leverage that allows me to charge a lot
of money to public speak or when my book
comes out it allows me to have a big fan
base to get a leverage of a big upfront
where I don't even need
books to sell though I want to fulfill
that contract it gave me the leverage to
start a social media agency with my
brain I could either then I operate it
around there's a lot of ways to make
money you've got to decide how if that's
even your goal I'm making the assumption
because it's a business oriented show
but it's all about content baby it's all
about content and what you're putting
out matters in two forms one is it
valuable to an audience that value
subjective but two how do you want to
communicate is it video form is it audio
form is it through amazingly cute and
amazing Instagram photos like what is it
that you do there's that moments in New
York or what's that guy people in New
York
that was just pictures on Instagram that
led to a big book do you like how do you
communicate do people like that and then
how do you decide to make money on it
that's really the game Rob asks Gary
what is the Facebook equivalent of
writing nest egg Rob with two bees first
of all India India is it true is it true
that Rob with two bees pisses you off
when there's two bees now that's how his
parents named him I mean this is a tough
place for you to go as a girl named
India it's true alright so I just just
wanted to establish that I mean you're
not Karen um sorry Karen's uh Robert ooh
bees it sounds like this is a little bit
of a black hat you know we're at least
gray hat facebook hack growth hacking
move would you listen I believe in being
smart and effective that seems to be
it's an interesting tactic but you've
nailed it and you edited your own post
so you nailed it you realize that cool
okay so there's some tool that's telling
you this video of a kid falling and the
snow is going viral why don't you just
take it and post it which will then work
because humans react to the same things
which will then boost your edge rank
right which allows other content that is
around Fitness to be seen by more people
so that would be the value of it but
you're right if you're putting out if
you're a fitness plate look look if I
ain't gary vaynerchuk's fan page start
putting out like penguins falling off
trees and like giraffes eating like sour
patch kids like you know like you know
ice skaters falling into the what
everything getting saved they were like
you know
the Mentos and pepsi thing like yeah I
mean that would bring me some general
awareness but it would also dilute why
people sign in for my channel you know
like you know if Spike TV now started
playing you know like soap operas maybe
they do okay may or a reality this was
the reality TV thing that a lot of
people struggled with like what do
people watch for I think media is
becoming agnostic so I think everybody
can play in a lot of genres so I think
the risk is actually better than it was
three or four years ago but I do think
that you can dilute your brand and get
away from it and if you're a fitness
channel I mean look what are you trying
to accomplish you know like like we're
all happy here and he just texted me I
think we're gonna get a million organic
views on the video and am i cool but
it's not accomplishing what I want are
the right million people gonna see my
Monday morning motivation video link
sorry Patrick you know yes but what am I
trying to achieve and trying to find
like-minded business hustle growing your
base and be appreciative gratitude
people I'm trying to grow more of my
audience you may get a million views on
that penguin jumping off a tree but did
they stay for your fitness if they don't
then you really accomplished nothing hey
Gary I'm sick today and I was just
curious if you ever get sick maybe you
really are Bionic man if you do get sick
how do you handle that how do you hustle
when you're sick really sick Ryan first
of all I hope you feel better I mean you
look like [ __ ] in that video um you know
a forceful big shout out to Lizzie
Vaynerchuk because in the last 11 years
that I've been married I have not been
sick I think I was a lot to do with the
fact that Lizzie tries to get me to wash
my hands and the fact that I don't have
a weird draft coming in like I had in my
old apartment which I think caught me a
couple times I mean uh uh you're talking
to an old school Eastern European kid
who actually thinks that getting sick
and being sick is actually psychology I
think the brain is the most powerful
tool like I know the answer this is not
true
but I do feel like I mean lying if I
didn't think there's some way that I'm
stopping myself from getting sick like
in the same way that I used to be able
to get myself sick to get out of school
and I don't mean like
oh my tummy hurts I mean in this weird
yeah I'm going somewhere I've never said
this out loud this is actually even
scary to say out loud I'm so convinced
that the brain is this powerful I used
to be able to create a temperature and I
know that every logical person including
myself I literally just said [ __ ]
but I saw it I mean I'm sure sometimes I
put it up to the lamp and that's how I
did it
but there was a couple of times where I
would just psych my even right now I
just started doing it and my stomach
turned a little bit I'm not kidding
nice the brain is a sick thing so I
guess the answer to the final question
is you know you don't hustle when you
get sick in the same way you don't
hustle want to get sleep you know we've
got that quote card it did really well
write that quote where I'm like it's not
what you do you know it's not how many
hours you're awake it's what you do
within them I'm thrilled to get six or
seven hours of sleep I love when people
think I'm on three or four hour guy I'll
take eight every night because those
other 16 I will dominate your face I
love people who sleep for hours but like
chill and I and chilling is like just
not doing something important for 40
minutes or like having a conversation on
the trading room floor for 30 minutes
about the big game or what the [ __ ]
happened in the Oscars last night who
gives a [ __ ] execute and so boy who
position for me I'm purely focusing I
think some people like thirty minutes of
talking about the Oscars because it
breaks up their day that's the rest you
do you but let me say this when you're
sick or when you're sleeping rest your
body's telling you something and so like
weirdly medium was sick once in the last
11 years I was pumped let me just say
that again because I don't know if
everybody understood that i weirdly wish
I'm not sick one day this year I
wouldn't really enjoy the time off I did
enjoy relaxing and the kids come you
know you should come swimming three like
gonna be fun it'd be fun but but there's
something subconsciously that's really
trying to not allow me to do that in a
world where I take 100-plus flights
where that place is like I don't know I
like you know remember how a couple of
celebs like I said the twenty to thirty
year old Gary Vee is soft compared to me
that guy did gets sick now I don't and I
do think it has a lot to do with my
focus on it so I do think you can out
hustle your sickness to some degree but
when you succumb to it because it's some
level we all do
I think you need to just relax and enjoy
it great question of the day a couple
things actually let's ago yeah chin you
know what I'm going back a little bit
one thing I'm not getting out of the
questions a day which I ask once every
20 to 30 is I need a critique of the
show we had Casey the other day as a
guest it's been a little bit sporadic
because I've been traveling a lot why
don't we do an episode 74 State of the
Union of where the show is that how you
feeling what what would you like to see
for me and I'd also like a little banter
you could talk about being sick you
could talk about the Oscars last night
and you could talk about my mundane
motivation video that's what's
acceptable in the comments you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering oh
crap wait subscribe I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe